you presumably should have been on a
ferry by now
yes we were due to leave london at four
o'clock ferry uh we've had nothing
complete for piano at all no
communications from them
so we're left to leave it high and dry
fortunately we've managed to book a
later ferry tonight with stenoline
uh
the
p o were trying to say that all their
tickets would be honored by stenaline
i'm afraid this turned out not to be
true and
staying alien don't know anything of
this so-called arrangement so hi we've
had the reboot we stand away now a cost
of 174 pounds
this is
unfortunate so so you find yourselves
now 174 pounds out of pocket extra that
you didn't intend to spend uh on on this
trip uh you've got the ferry booked
which obviously you you know great that
you were able to make that uh that
booking in the first place
have you tried calling piano
yes
frequently
all morning couldn't get any couldn't
get through to anybody's everything was
engaged uh you're close
or just ringing out
hopelessly
we were just abandoned all the
passengers were just abandoned we've
been reading stuff online this has
happened to everybody who's tried to
you know try to board a piano fairy
they've just been lifetimed right we
were lucky that we were able to you know
rebook but it's it's bad enough for us
the few sailors 800 people have just
lost their jobs which are
is even worse
and and for you i imagine once you get
home once you're on the other side of of
this journey you'll be looking to get
that refund from uh piano uh how
confident are you that you're going to
get through to their customer service i
mean it doesn't sound like it's been
very responsive over the last few hours
we'll certainly be trying to get the
money back from p o and what our chances
are i wouldn't like to say i would
imagine that customer service says if
you can call it that will be pretty much
swamped at the moment with people like
ourselves
and
uh it's going to be a busy day
we're not optimistic that we'll see your
money to be perfectly honest with you
and i mean i'm looking at where you are
now it doesn't look like you're at the
port yet have you gone to see what the
port looks like yeah are you going to
get there very early
yeah well we'll be leaving here about
half an hour to head for belfast uh from
what i can gather this absolutely what
we've seen online it's absolutely
pointless for us to go to the piano
ferry uh atlanta it's
there's nothing happening apart from
apparently there's a private security
company been called to get
the crew on off the crew refusing to
leave
uh
for obvious reasons if they've just been
sacked
so no we will we won't be going to alarm
we're still in port rush but we'll be
leaving in the next half hour yeah well
i guess to be in good time because i
don't want to scare you but i imagine
there's a lot of people who've done a
similar thing to you rebooked onto steny
you want to make sure you get onto those
uh onto those boats jackie what were you
what were you doing in northern ireland
was this supposed to be a relaxation
holiday
it certainly was yes
for her first break of hopefully many
this year come over here quite regularly
okay okay and i mean you both look in
very good spirits it obviously hasn't
sort of traumatized you too much are you
hoping that you'll still feel the
effects of the holiday when you get home
where are you going to be dealing with
this for the next few weeks
hopefully we'll still feel the effects
of it and
obviously we'll need to spend time
trying to get our money back if we can
um but as gavin says there's loads of
people have lost their jobs and that's a
lot worse than what we've lost yeah
absolutely and we must keep those 800 uh
people in mind absolutely wilson thank
you so much for talking to us uh both of
you uh gavin and jackie shaw i wish you
the best for your journey i hope it goes
as smoothly as it can given what you've
already gone through
and that you get back home safely
okay thank you bye